ready to go
thank you very much are we long
thank you very much
okay
uh
welcome to this meeting of the
mid-suffolk licensing and regulatory
committee i am councillor dave muller
vice chair of the licensing and
regulatory committee and i will be
chairing the meeting today
i will now read out the domestic
arrangements
please ensure that you maintain social
distance from all other persons whilst
in the chamber and the communal areas
please ensure that you wear a face
covering at all times unless you are
seated or if you are exempt from doing
so and that you use the hand sanitizer
and wipes provided
you will be invited to speak and ask
questions by the chair
please do not interrupt other speakers
if you are attending the meeting to
speak
and persistently interrupt the meeting
you may be asked to leave
please ensure that microphones are
turned off when not in use
please ensure mobile phones are on
silent or switched off
additionally we will be using the
e-voting on modern.gov app for this
meeting please could members therefore
ensure they are logged in and ready to
use the app
i would like to remind everyone present
that this meeting will be broadcast live
to the internet and will be capable of
repeated viewing
the whole of the meeting will be
recorded except where there are
confidential or exempt items
if you make a representation to the
meeting you will be deemed by the
council to have consented to being
recorded
by entering this meeting as a speaker
you are also consenting to being
recorded by the council and to the
possible use of those same recordings
for webcasting and or training purposes
the council members of the public and
the press may record film photograph or
broadcast this meeting when the public
and the press are not lawfully excluded
i will now make the introductions to the
officers that are here today we have
emma richbelt who is the assistant
manager for food safety and licensing
catherine greene licensing officer
k sanders licensing officer
nigel dulu the legal adviser and karen
sayer who is the governor's officer
can i now move to the agenda please
do we have any apologies for absence
thank you chair we've received apologies
from councillor epinyong councillor geek
and councillor guthrie
thank you very much do we have any
declarations of interest by councillors
council stringer
thank you sorry chair on the on the
attendance
although the papers don't say that
councillor turner is a committee member
the modern.gov app does
if you're right actually i noticed that
came to string about he's quite right
actually on that uh jam it does mention
cakes turner on those
i think she'd been added to the meeting
for today as a substitute in error
you
okay so
um i'd like to move on to item three mlr
stroke 21 stroke one to confirm the
minutes of the meeting held on the 2nd
of october 2020
are there any points regarding the
accuracy of the minutes please
and these are on page
seven
and eight of your papers
therefore could i have a proposer and a
second of please
counselor brewster and propose a
councillors um
as the
seconder thank you very much
okay can we go to the vote please
thank you chair councillors could you
please open the modern.gov app
by clicking the plus sign in the top
right of the agenda and selecting
attendance and voting
in the voting tab the vote for this item
will now show in blue
[Applause]
[Applause]
that's six votes for chair
thank you very much the minutes have
been confirmed and will be signed at the
end of the meeting thank you
item four on the agenda to receive
notification of petitions in accordance
with the council's petition scheme
none received chair thank you very much
question five questions by councillors
i believe chair you've got questions
there in front of you from councillor
string i have that's correct yes um
council stringer do you have any
objection if we if you raise these
questions during the item um the next
item on the agenda which is a new
hackney carriage and private hire
vehicle that'd be functioning you're
happy with that thank you very much
okay therefore i will move on to item
six which is the mlr stroke 21 stroke
two the new hackney carriage and private
hire vehicle licensing policy and i will
now invite
the licensing officer k sanders to
introduce the report please thank you
kate
thank you chair
this report refers to the review of the
current hackney carriage and private
hard vehicle licensing policy for the
controlled zone of mid-suffolk district
council
officers have undertaken an extensive
review of the current policy operating
within the district and in doing so have
attempted to align the independent
policies currently in place in both
baber and mid-suffolk
the draft policy for mid-suffolk is
attached as appendix a to this report
the review has been lengthy and it was
necessary due to the introduction of the
statutory standards published by the
department for transport in july 2020
the focus of the new statutory taxi and
private hard vehicle standards is on
protecting children and vulnerable
adults however all passengers will
benefit from the recommendations
the overarching aim of the statutory
standards is public protection
the licence and team's first steps were
to involve the trade in the early stages
of the review to engage and obtain their
ideas
so
to engage their ideas for the policy
moving forward
this engagement involved a virtual
meeting held with the trade in july
2020. unfortunately due to covered
we were unable to hold the meeting in
person but many members of the trade did
attend virtually and offered their
opinions and suggestions which we
captured and fed into the review
the changes likely to have the greatest
impact were identified early on in the
review and they are
vehicle age policy has been added for
mid-south district council
drivers have never had an age policy for
their vehicle and a lot of them may find
it difficult to finance new vehicles
however the team have identified this
and have allowed for more frequent
frequent testing for older vehicles to
allow the driver to retain the vehicle
and the team ensure the vehicle remains
safe and suitable to be driven
currently the licensing team undertake a
knowledge test however there will be a
mandatory requirement to undertake the
introduction of the role of professional
taxi and private hard drives course the
mandatory requirement to undertake the
course will have financial implications
for drivers and operators but will
ensure that all drivers and operators
are certified and have the correct
awareness of the expectations
of their job wrong
as part of the review the taxi policy
must be sent out by consultation and the
statutory standard sets out who councils
should be consulting in respect of any
changes the authority wishes to make
the licensing team is well-versed in
consultations and has the necessary
contacts to undertake a wide-ranging
consultation exercise over a 28-day
period a list of identified key
consultations attached to this report as
appendix c
once the consultation period has been
completed any responses will be collated
and the draft hackney carriage and
private higher license and policy may be
revised in the light of the
representation's comments made any
revised document will then be brought
back before the licensing and regulatory
committee at the next next meeting in
october 2021 for further consideration
prior to the document being recommended
onto cabinet for adoption
recommendation
that the committee approves the draft
hackney carriage and private hard
vehicle policy document attaches
appendix aid for consultation
further that the relevant officers
proceed with the 28-day consultation
period with the licensed trade general
public and other relevant stakeholders
and just to know all grammatical and
personalization errors will be rectified
before bringing this matter back to the
committee on 15th of october this
concludes murraycourt the team will be
happy to answer any questions
thank you very much okay
do we have any questions for the
licensing officer please
coach the stringer then kate stewart
thank you yeah thank you
looking looking in through the report uh
regarding uh move to uh more sustainable
fuels and stuff and uh
and zero emission fuels
uh the policy seems to be reactive if it
happens
rather than
proactively helping the change which is
in stark contrast to some other
licensing policies that are out there
have we
considered
as others have
actually
assisting in the transition to
cleaner vehicles rather than keeping
older vehicles going for longer
i've got the response from the licensing
team council stringer which i'll read
out to you thank you for your question
the licensing team are currently still
undertaking research into incentives but
we are aware of several incentives both
from central government and more locally
as part of this policy review though the
team have identified that further
research is required to ensure that this
council has a robust incentive scheme in
order to fully benefit the trade and
strongly encourage the move to a greener
fleet the licensing team on next review
of this policy or sooner hoped to
circulate to this committee a fully
formed incentive scheme to make way for
a more carbon neutral fleet
in the interim the team would be happy
to work with the council if there were
any incentives that they may be able to
offer
do you have any supplementary questions
for that character i think yeah i do
give given the
year before last i think we declared a
climate emergency
surely we can learn from what's deemed
best practice elsewhere uh i mean i
found two this morning
that there is a 35 000 pound loan if
someone wishes to convert their vehicle
to
electric and all of the taxi ranks and
that authority have as part of the
license for you have access to free
power there as well right
so
that's actually as it were front loading
the transition and making it happen
sooner and i was hoping that that if we
declared this reaction
to climate change as an emergency that
there would it would be in the policy
we're about to review given it's been a
decade since the last review
and if we roll forward a decade you'll
have at least been a year into not being
able to buy a fossil fuel vehicle so i
was rather hoping that it would be we
wouldn't be deciding to do some research
it should actually be in the policy
now as a plan of how we do
migrate thank you thank you council
stringer could i ask the licensing team
to look into counter stringer's points
please david would you like to comment
on that as the vehicle part of policy
please
thank you yeah
um
yeah
yes chad i think that's one thing that
we will have to go back and have a look
at
properly and appropriately and have the
appropriate conversations
uh well
i
i don't really want to sign off a policy
if it's got something quite major
missing from it as in a plan of how
we're going to do this and how we're
going to assist
uh our fleet in in in
migrating because if we haven't got a
plan
of how we're going to support and and i
recognize there's some reluctance to
migrate to vehicles that are more
expensive to buy and deemed more hassle
to get around in by by some
there needs to be a clear plan rather
than we ending up with a policy where we
have to react to everyone else moving on
when they they will probably then be
more efficient deemed more efficient and
we may lose business
they will be included in the
plan please
yesterday well there are very some
um
so
there are various um
bodies that we can that drivers can go
to we have the information which we're
willing which we will share with each
one that wants to go forward with
electric vehicles
however
um yes we will be going forward with um
talking to
the reverend
people internally to get a budget for
for things like that i would hope so
is that right
thank you chair i mean the only comment
i would make was in the original draft
policy we were perhaps a little stronger
in pushing for the um greener vehicles
but um the difficulty is that we have
quite a uh the fleet in mid-suffolk are
largely self-employed drivers that would
need a lot of assistance and there would
be perhaps a need for you know political
decision as to what grants we might make
and so on so
yes
we can see in principle there's a need
for it but it's we need to balance it
against the trades viability um so
that's why we it's yeah
we want we want to move that direction
but we're concerned about too much of an
impact on the trade and being viable in
the
future
well well yeah i mean what will give
people certainty is
certainty a policy
having looked at other policies where it
says you can only license this array of
vehicles i was quite shocked uh but
within it there's the stick but there's
also the carrot of the but and if you
want to migrate to one of these vehicles
here here is where you get the funding
and by the way the infrastructure is
already there for you that we've put in
for you
that's called a plan that's a reaction
to an emergency
you know
the taxi drivers are going to have a
real struggle
uh and getting to their customers if
they're if they're trying to drive
through flood and fire and you know and
we get the worse that the climate
control is uh it is an emergency and i
don't see any emergency in this plan
uh frankly
sorry and i realize it's political
but
it's not something you can bargain with
and we either have a plan of how we're
going to assist our taxi drivers
or we don't have one
and it looks at the moment that we don't
have one
i think only only to say that i
i completely hear what you're saying and
we we have to balance it between other
political views um
we had quite a strong view from another
councillor about you know the concern
about the viability of the trade so it's
that's that difficult balance isn't it
clearly
just come back on that given the court
case last uh last year in london with
the girl that died from uh
respiratory problems directly attributed
to emissions
when
communities start banning these vehicles
that are killing people from their
localities how viable will those taxi
services be then
they won't be viable at all so it's
about creating that assistance to make
them viable in the next 10 years because
if our if our taxi fleet doesn't migrate
to zero emissions within the next five
to six years
i don't think they'll be viable beyond
them because they will then be
struggling to buy vehicles with no
support when everyone else is migrated
so they'll be priced out of the market
so
i was i was looking for it to be
assistance rather than just say well
it's a bit difficult so we won't bother
it is all very difficult uh but it's not
a political decision that we've declared
a climate emergency we unanimously
agreed it was an emergency so i was
hoping to see some reaction to that
emergency in our policies going forward
and i'm disappointed that i can't see it
in here thank you
occasionally you also raised a second
question do you want to cover that now
the question you raised was what plans
are there for ev charge point convenient
for stone market taxis obviously this is
a taxi company based it's a stone market
railway station
the response for the licensing team is
that the licensing team as part of this
policy review did identify that there
are is several constraints in requiring
drivers to move toward a greener fleet
and the charging point access was a
concern raised the team are unaware of
any plans that may already be in place
for ev charging point on the stone
market rank but we will ensure that we
forward these concerns to the climate
change strategy team to ensure that this
is a consideration however the team feel
that charging points on the rank would
impede trade as the vehicle is supposed
to be for immediate higher when parked
on the rank it may be advisable to
locate these charging points near near
rather than on the rank
can i just come back on it
i don't understand that that that's not
logical
if if a taxi is charging on a rank it
can be deployed in about two seconds
right uh so so that's the ideal place to
have a charging point is on the rank
that's where everyone else has put them
yeah that's where dundee have got them
and and the the power is free if you're
a licensed taxi uh that to me seems an
obvious thing to do so why are we
suggesting it's difficult
okay would you like to come
that's fine it's just we are unaware of
how long it takes to charge an electric
vehicle so if if if it's quick then
that's fine because they do have to they
are available for high so they just have
to go they they can't stop so
but you're saying that that's fine
that's okay for them to be on the rank
then yeah that's fine that's good that's
the point while they're waiting for
someone to hail them
they can be charging up
if it's five minutes ten minutes it
doesn't matter they're at least charging
on their downtime
and the more of them you get the more
ranks you get the more ability and the
easier it will be able to migrate so
it's actually part of encouraging that
migration as well to have
near the ranks or at the ranks charging
points it does make sense okay thank you
very much now i know council often i
know you put your hand up count so
practice robin you had a question you
raised your hand earlier
uh yeah um obviously at the moment it's
not obligatory for somebody to wear a
face mask
in public transport
but i just wonder how the council is
proceeding at the moment um where we are
still getting considerable number of
positive
covid cases
um and whether it's just this accounts
can the council only
be advisory
um as far as taxes are concerned and my
other question under the equality
analysis
as it says there are no equality
implications arising i would just want
it confirmed
that
all equality
policies
includes
all persons of
transgender
that is correct
yes
this with with with respect to council
ron's first part of the question
regarding the wearing a face mask is
this can we just do it on an advisory
basis or is this down to the companies
themselves
the individual taxi driver if it's not
compulsory i think we can only do it as
advisory but they would need to do their
covert risk assessment
um
and i would say in that risk assessment
it would be a necessity to wear masks
but we can't actually enforce that
unless it's compulsory
if i may add i take a point actually
because i personally would wear a mask
you know not just for my protective
protection the driver as well so and i
think a lot of people still actually do
do that so thank you for that question
cait straight bottom um thanks for
practice
thank you
um sure oh there we go
um
yeah it's just basically a question that
sort of reiterates
council stringer's point earlier about
the electrification of taxis
um i think you know there's a bit of a
chicken and egg
game when it comes to people deciding
whether to buy an electric car per se
they're worried about where they're
going to charge their cars and
especially in urban areas where people
might not be able to have access to a
private charging point it sort of
reinforces the need for public ones
um
and i i think it's the same with with
taxis really more taxi drivers will be
sort of convinced to buy an electric
car for work if they feel that they can
reliably charge
their taxis at the rank or in various
other locations for free
um
i was i was just thinking you know i was
my question is whether
the licensing
team has
reached out or talked to supper county
council
about electrification of the taxi ranks
because i know
um
peter frost for example
um
the officer southern county council
he
has been working to deliver
community charging hubs
via a stow market based company called
eo charging and these sorts of
partnerships would work really well
because we would be using a local
company to to install the infrastructure
as well
thank you
i don't believe we have
that's something we need to do
good idea actually yeah thank you thank
you coach
um do we have any more questions from
members
therefore i will open up the item for
debate
does anyone wish to debate
no
okay therefore
um the recommendation as previously read
out by the licensing officer on page
nine of our papers
that the committee approves the draft
hackney carriage and private vehicle
hire policy document attaches appendix a
for consultation
further that the relevant officers
proceed with a 28-day consultation
period with the licensed trade general
public and other relevant
stakeholders um could i please ask the
government's officer now to con to
conduct the electronic vote we need a
proposal chair oh sorry can i have a
proposal and a second to please
councillor brewster to propose happy to
propose the recognition
thank you chair
councillors could you please open the
vote in the modern.gov app
so there's nothing amended to it to
cover the work we're going to do
encouraging the migration to zero
emission vehicles
nothing in there at all
yeah happy to add that in
that we you know do encourage people to
move to um
hearing electric vehicles
please
sorry respect you i think it's
it was i think we were promised slightly
more than that we would try and get a
policy where one doesn't exist uh
although we didn't get a time frame on
this work that will be done it needs to
be done quite urgently
yes
but also to help make our taxi fleet
viable in the longer term
i i frankly can't support the document
without it
fair enough well i say we
if we can add something in
to that effect that um that it will be
looked at urgently
as a matter of urgency because of the
climate change emergency
chad we need to um make an amendment to
the recommendation i believe then yes we
do yeah and that needs to be agreed by
the proposal in second down are the
proposed and second are happily happy
with that amendment
we have a policy that doesn't have a
policy
about a migration that we need we have a
policy of doing nothing which is what
this policy suggests do it doing very
little as policy
okay i'm suggesting we should have a
policy
that shows how we can migrate
and how we're responding to this at the
moment we're just saying the policy is
let's keep the oldest most polluting
vehicles going as long as we can that's
our policy at the moment i'm suggesting
that's not a good policy
or one that's going to be lawful within
the time period of this policy we're
about to agree
um
we can we can have that as the policy if
you want and i can't vote for it what i
was trying to do is get consensus and
actually get it written down but if we
haven't got it then we haven't got it
it's fine i recognize the politics of
the situation but frankly this didn't
want to be
political this ought to be
we know where we're going we agree where
we're going and we
shine it in policy and that we should
well we're either timid about it we're
not others are not timid about it and
they are saying you will not have a
vehicle that's x and y and it will be
from this approved list only
but that but that's a stick and but the
carrot is you will get the funding and
there will be the charging
infrastructure already in place
i would suggest we need to move to that
policy but if we don't then we don't but
i can't support it if we don't
if yeah if i could just assist a little
bit here um
clearly what counselor string is asking
for is basically a different policy
and that's not going to happen here and
now um what you have before you is is a
vote on a policy that's in the report
and i think today you're going to have
to vote on that policy with you for it
or not i think that motion has to go
through as it stands today thank you for
that in that view we will vote against
the policy that's in front of us today
thank you thank you nigel
thank you
are you happy with that came to brewster
and coach flatman as the second year
thank you
are you happy for me to proceed to the
vote chair yes please thank you thank
you
councillors if you could please open the
vote in the modern.gov app by clicking
the plus sign
and this agenda um this vote should now
be showing in blue
okay that's three four and three against
chair
right moving on to item agenda 7 which
is paper mlr stroke 21 stroke 3 gambling
act 2005 statement of principles
statutory three yearly revision can i
now invite the licensing officer k
sanders please to introduce the report
thank you chair
this report refers to policy setting
under the gambling act 2005. since
january 2007 local licensing authorities
have been responsible for functions
under the gambling act 2005 including
issuing of licences and permits for
gambling gaming premises and associated
matters
section 349 of the 2005 act requires
each license licensing authority to
prepare and publish a statement of the
higher level principles it will apply
when dispensing its various gambling
functions the statement of principles
must by law be reviewed and republished
every three years or sooner if so
required
this year the authority is due to
revisit the statement
that has been in fact since 20 20 19.
and this report seeks the approval of
the suitability suitability revised
version in order that the statutory
consultation period may then commence on
its content
the redrafted statement attached as
appendix aid to this report contains
amendments from the 2019 published
version
these revisions have been collated in a
summary document and is attached to the
report as appendix b
the gambling commission revised national
guidance document to licensing
authorities originally published in
september 2015 as amended in april 2021
has influenced some of the revised draft
content when formulating the local
statement of principal's revision
the legislation requires the license
authority to consult widely upon its
draft statement of principles document
with stakeholders before finalizing and
publishing the document in january 2022
as set by order of the secretary of
state the six statements will take
effect for a three-year period from the
31st of january 2022 through to the 31st
of january 2025
although the statement may be revised
sooner if necessary
based on an officer review of the
gambling activity over the past three
year period the fee table attached as
appendix c
representing the maxima which may be
charged by regulation for the various
application and process types under the
act
is proposed for approval unaltered
costs which may be appropriated to the
fees include all aspects of
administering and maintaining the scheme
it should be noted that both baba and
mid-south district councils also have a
limited base of gambling authorizations
and activity upon which to apportion
some of the cost elements
recommendations note a slight amendment
has been made to the recommendations
that the draft revision of the gambling
act 2005 statement of principles
document attached to its appendix a be
approved for consultation further that
the relevant officers proceed with the
commencement of a period of statutory
consultation in accordance with the
gambling act
2005 legislation and regulations that
the table of fees attaches apparently
for the gambling act 2005 functions be
adopted to take effect from the 31st of
january 2022.
no questions at all
no
okay if there are no questions i'll now
open up the um item for debate
do you remember this we should debate
this particular item
oh okay it's a stringer well i say yes
thank you thank you
it's sort of uh the sixth edition of
this isn't it we've revised this has
been been going along and as you write
he said we have a very low level
of licenses in this area
all of the
all of the stuff in here all seems
fairly
self-explanatory and common sense and in
line with the objectives
i can't think of any any reason that we
shouldn't support
this because it's quite in line i think
that's all i've got to say thank you i
want my moving approval
of the document thank you coach stringer
case rotten please
oops i mean i suppose my only comment is
that we are hearing more and more about
people that have become addicted to
gambling of one form or another
and therefore i think it's important
that the council works with other
organizations to support people who do
end up
having a severe gambling problem and of
course a lot of that problem
is done online
whereby you know the local authorities
may well not have any
knowledge of what is happening but i
think it is an area
that we should be supporting
organizations that do help people with a
gambling addiction
thank you for that
that's a good point
there is just one element i forgot to
mention it's on my notes
under eight traveling fares
[Music]
do we have a policy of live animal
prizes
sorry can i ask the licensing officer
do we have a policy of live animal
prizes
did we not ought to have a policy as to
whether we allow live animals to be
prizes affairs
as far as the team aware that wouldn't
come under the gambling act
do we still have fairs locally
come across any at all
you have two a year in stonewall really
i don't think i've ever heard of it
yeah
okay thank you very much um do any other
members wish to debate this topic
therefore the recommendations are 3.1
that the draft version revision of the
gambling act 2005 statement of
principles document attaches appendix a
b approved for consultation
further that the relevant officers
proceed with the commencement of a
period of statutory consultation in
accordance with gambling act 2005
legislation and regulations and
recommendation 3.2 that the table of
fees attach an appendix c for gambling
act 2005 functions be adopted to take
effect from the 31st of january
2022. can i have a proposal please and a
secondary
for those recommendations
counter-stringer is proposed so can have
a second to please kaiser flatman thank
you very much could i ask the governor's
officer please no to go to the
electronic vote thank you thank you
chair councillors could you please open
this vote in the modern.gov app
the vote for this agenda item will now
show in blue
[Applause]
[Applause]
that's 6'4 chair thank you very much
indeed thank you i'll now move on to
agenda item number eight
which is mlr stroke 21 stroke four
and can i ask
kay sanders please to
report on this piece and to introduce a
report thank you chair
the purpose of this report is to ask
committee to consider the evidence
before them in regard of the no casino
resolution and make a recommendation to
request that full council determine
whether to adopt an ococena resolution
the key evidence within this report is
as follows
as the full
allocation for casinos under the act has
been granted
eight large eight small one regional
casino there is no provision available
for a casino license to be granted
it would need as it would need a
suitable economic climate and the
political will of the government for the
secretary of state to lay legislation
for further allocation allocation of
casinos
there would be a requirement for me to
suffolk to bid on such an allocation if
another provision of casinos were ever
to become available a further allocation
is highly unlikely to happen in the
foreseeable future
and central government are currently
tightening restrictions in regard to
gambling
the original concern regarding casinos
steamed from a planning application
forcing oasis which included plans to
have a casino as part of the proposed
activities on the site
the application has since been withdrawn
and the new proposed development in this
area at valley ridge has removed all
reference to the provision of a casino
mid-suffolk district council licensed
authority have received no applications
for a casino from when the 2005 act came
into force to the present day
researchers also identified that none of
the surrounding districts and borough
councils that and mid-south district
council have adopted a no-casino
resolution
this is a decision that can only be made
by full council
that concludes my summary chair thank
you thank you
no
okay i will open up the
sorry case often apologies um i mean
has the council had any approaches by
any
organizations in the last couple of
years no no thank you
right i know open up this for debate
does anyone wish to debate
councillor prattling counter-stringer
yeah i believe you know being a largely
rural district there isn't really need
for casinos or mega casino
kind of infrastructure really i think
you know echoing what council rotten
said earlier
you know gambling can compound problems
of addiction and
mental health issues and poverty um
personally um i would be against any
such kind of casino in this district
thank you can you string it please
yeah um
it's taken a while for this to get
debated
i have to say things sometimes don't
grind very
fast in local government worlds
the
i would actually be in favor of of
making a no casino uh resolution uh for
a couple of
uh strong points
the
amount i take the point that the
government
has not got any in it
it's offering out at the moment but but
governments can change very quickly as
we're finding out in other parts of the
world today
that's not to say that's going to happen
here but
government thinking can change very
quickly it's certainly in a fast-moving
economic climate
i think
for a rural area such as mid-suffolk a
casino
however
small or large
in my own opinion and certainly most of
the people that i've consulted
would feel a very negative thing for us
economically socially environmentally
so therefore if you had the resolution
it then
gives the whole world a clear indication
that we wouldn't want one here thank you
very much
uh which which stops
people
taking a punt as it were
in running after things that are
fanciful
uh and and spending thousands of pounds
on drawing up plans for something that
we would
not wish to support
uh and frankly if we could have had a no
casino resolution
before
snow aces was put on the table
i would have decided that i think that
would have helped an awful lot with the
the hundreds of thousands have been
spent
chasing their tales on something that's
never come to light
so
i think it it's it's not saying that
with incredibly anti-gambling it's just
giving the whole world that that
indication that frankly we don't think
we're the right place uh and and if you
really have to have one probably be best
somewhere more urban or elsewhere rather
than rural suffolk so that's how i feel
jeff thank you thank you for your
comments council stringer obviously as
we've said the actual decision for this
will actually have to be made by full
council
so
in the meantime we have the
recommendations which i will again read
out
recommendation 3.1 that the licensing a
regulatory committee in considering the
evidence base make a recommendation
accounts on whether to adopt a no casino
resolution and 3.2 but if the council
resolves not to adopt a no casino
resolution this matter would not be
debated again unless the allocation
under the gambling act 2005 is increased
by the secretary of state
can i have a proposal and a second to
please coach the brewster to propose
and councillor flatman two seconds thank
you very much could i please ask the
governance officer to undertake the um
the vote please thank you
thank you chair councillors could you
please open the vote again in the
modern.gov app and this vote should now
be showing in blue
[Applause]
i would tell you how to vote
that's 64 chair thank you very much
indeed
um thank you everybody that actually um
concludes today's meeting thank you for
all for attending and the next proposed
meeting is on friday the 15th of october
at 10 30 a.m
thank you everybody thank you
you